I have sad news for you and it, it really
is sad.
I'm not being satirical in any way.
Uh, the next democratic debate is going to
be the worst one yet, and this is con as bad
as previous democratic debates have been this
election cycle.
The next one, which is number four in the
middle of this month will be the worst one
because the requirements to get into the debate
aren't strict enough at this late stage in
the game, just a couple of months from when
voting, we'll actually start in the democratic
primary.
We have 12 people that have qualified for
the fourth debate and the entire debate is
going to take place on one night.
We are going to have 12 candidates.
On the stage at the same time, and I've told
you before, 10 candidates on the stage times
two nights for 20 total candidates.
There are many problems there.
You don't see all the candidates on the stage
together so you can't really evaluate them
on the basis of how they all talk to each
other.
You had nights where Warren and Bernie were
split up.
You had nights where Biden was separated from
other front runners, so that was a problem
and then at the same time with 10 people on
the stage each night, the level of depth was
very low because you had 10 people competing
for speaking time.
So when the number of people who qualified
for the fourth debate, which is on October
15th hit 10 and then had hit 11 and then hit
12 the immediate question was are they going
to do two debates with six people on each
stage, which might actually allow for a little
bit more depth.
Even if we are splitting up the candidates
onto two stages and the answer is no.
CNN, which is co-hosting this debate with
the New York times is decided they are going
to do one night, 12 candidates all on the
same stage and between CNN again co-hosting
the debate, which was just terrible last time,
right wing framing of questions.
Um, we, they shut down my live stream of the
debate as you might remember, and more candidates
than ever on the stage at once.
This is just going to be terrible.
That's the reality.
The debate is going to be on Tuesday, October
15th at 8:00 PM Eastern time.
We will attempt to live coverage of course,
and the reality is that no one can look good
with 12 people on the stage, especially when
you're answering poorly framed questions from
the moderators.
So who's responsible here?
Is it CNN and the New York times for wanting
it to be on one night?
Is it the democratic national committee for
accepting that it all be done on one night?
Who has the power here?
It's not completely clear, but what I can
tell you for sure.
What is very clear is that they are making
the debates, not only unwatchable but completely
useless in terms of actually providing us
with the information that we need to accurately
and in an informed way determine who it is
we want to support in the 2020 democratic
primary it.
Now let's do a little math.
If with 12 candidates onstage, if the debate
ran three hours with no commercials, that's
180 minutes, 12 candidates, that's 15 minutes
per candidate, so that's already not great.
Like if I'm going to decide who I'm supporting,
I want to hear from them for more than just
15 minutes.
But again, that's with no breaks with no anything
else.
Remember that the last CNN debate started
with some overly produced sports game, like
introduction opening statements from candidates,
which I find completely useless and a commercial
break.
Before the first question, it was 25 minutes
into the scheduled start of the debate before
the first question was asked.
They also were scheduled for three hours or
maybe for two, but in any case, they ended
up 20 minutes shy of three hours.
So you take away 25 minutes from the front,
you take away 20 minutes from the end, and
on that basis each candidate gets a little
over 11 minutes to speak.
And then if we add in the fact that they are
taking a couple of commercial breaks throughout
the entire thing, what you end up with with
12 candidates on the stage effectively in
a quote three hour debate is 10 minutes of
speaking time per candidate.
This is not how I want to pick a presidential
candidate.
It's embarrassingly bad.
And then of course, there's also the issue
of the fact that with absolutely no chance
of winning, you have candidates participating
and taking away from important conversations
that we could be having.
I'll give you an example.
Imagine if Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren
and Joe Biden could spend 45 minutes, just
the three of them talking about exactly how
their healthcare plans would work.
We would be able to actually press Joe Biden
on how not progressive his health care plan
is.
Bernie Sanders would be able to actually hash
out with Elizabeth Warren.
Okay.
Well, Elizabeth, if you're open to Medicare
for all, but you're also open to other options,
give me one of those other options.
Let's debate in detail how one of the other
options would work, but it's not going to
happen.
We're going to hear from, you know, irrelevant
nonsense from Tom Stier and Tulsi Gabard and
Amy Klobuchar and other people who have no
at this.
It's going to be terrible.
I will be watching of course, a, but it is
not going to be a debate that will leave us
drastically more informed in depth about the
positions of the candidates that actually
have a shot at this thing.
Uh, mistakes all around.
And unfortunately the debates seem to be getting
worse as we go.
Not better.